[Music]
for our daily cancellation today we must
cancel will smith we could cancel him
because he hasn't made a good movie in
20 years but his filmography isn't the
topic of contention today our focus now
is on smith's recent interview in gq
where he discusses the beauty and wonder
of being in an open marriage
will smith is in an open marriage with
his wife jada pinkett smith though it
appears that the marriage was initially
opened
against his will um the couple
infamously sat across from each other
for a red table talk on facebook last
year where they awkwardly in front of
the cameras
discussed an affair that jada had years
before um
i've never been able to watch more than
a minute of this conversation because
the cringe factor is so overwhelming
but just to refresh our memories here's
a little bit of that discussion watch
this
you
[Music]
during that time launched into an
interaction
with august what do you feel like
um you were looking for
i just wanted to feel good
it had been so
long
since i felt
good
and it was really a joy to just
help heal somebody yeah
i think that has a lot to do with my
codependency
which is another thing that i had to
learn to break in this cycle just that
idea of needing to fix and being drawn
to people that need help whether it's
your health or whether it's your
addictions there's something about
that childhood trauma
um
that
feels as though it can be fixed
through
fixing people
yeah well that's one way to put it she
she was not starting an affair she was
as well puts it launching into an
interaction
there's some nice euphemistic language
that you might want to try if you're a
dirty rotten cheater caught in the act
oh no honey i wasn't cheating i was
really just i was having an interaction
you know we kind of launched into this
interaction there was an exchange you
might say
an understanding was reached a meeting
of the minds and end of other parts
of course i'm imagining the cheater
making the excuses for themselves here
but actually will smith is the one
providing the euphemisms to the wife who
cheated on him and for her part she's a
little bit more direct because he asks
what were you looking for when you
cheated on me and she says i just wanted
to feel good
and he says oh okay
as if that sheds comforting new light on
the situation but obviously she cheated
because it made her feel good that's why
any cheater cheats it's why any bad
person does anything bad that's the
motivating factor behind all sin you do
it because it makes you feel good and
you have prioritized feeling good over
all other concerns especially your
commitments your promises your moral
obligations that's why every bad person
does bad things
so that was last year now will smith is
in gq talking about his free and open
marriage and how happy and loving it all
is reading from the daily wire report it
says
uh quote jaina never believed in
conventional marriage smith told gq jada
had family members that had an
unconventional relationship so she grew
up in a way that was very different than
how i grew up there were significant
endless discussions about what is
relational perfection smith recalled and
for the large part of our relationship
monogamy was that choi
choice not thinking of monogamy as the
only relational perfection the pair have
given each other trust and freedom
within their relationship page six noted
uh since marriage can't be a prison will
smith said
quote i don't suggest our road for
anybody i don't suggest this road for
anybody but the experience is that the
freedoms that we've given one another
and the unconditional support to me is
the highest definition of love
it was a lot of that was quite
incoherent but hopefully you basically
got the idea the highest definition of
love is betrayal he says or rather it's
it's doing what makes you feel good
individually
in other words the highest love in a
marriage is self-interest
that is what will smith proposes and
what makes it all the sadder and more
pitiable is that you can tell he doesn't
really believe a word of what he's
saying this is how these open marriages
work there's usually one member of the
couple who feels betrayed and is being
betrayed it has to convince themselves
that they're not being betrayed
when you listen to the stories of
couples and open marriages you always
hear either the husband or the wife say
yeah you know my spouse decided that
it'd be a good idea for them to sleep
with other people and you know i was
utterly and completely devastated and
destroyed by it at first but over time
i've learned to accept it and i'm really
so happy now
when i'm not locking myself in the
bathroom and weeping uncontrollably five
times a day
an open marriage is after all
betrayal as a lifestyle
and betrayal doesn't become any less
traitorous just because it's done in the
open
that actually makes it worse if anything
because now you've enlisted your spouse
to be an accomplice in your infidelity
you don't even have the decency to cheat
in secret and save them the indignity
and the shame of pretending that they're
okay with it
an open marriage is also an oxymoron
it's a contradiction in terms it's like
open borders
if you open a border then it's not a
border anymore if you open a marriage
that's not a marriage anymore a marriage
by definition is closed a marriage can't
be opened for the same reason that you
know you can't build a house without
walls or a roof the walls in the roof
are the whole point of the house get rid
of those and now you're homeless
a blanket laid out on the pavement is
not an open house or a new house or a
consensually non-walled house
it's just not a house it's a non-house
it's literally the opposite of a house
and if we start calling that a house
then we haven't expanded the definition
of a house but instead we've done away
with the very concept of a house
entirely and i think that would be a
very stupid thing to do because houses
are very useful things to have just like
marriages marriage has its own walls and
its own roof and it's within those walls
and under that roof that your family
must be formed and maintained monogamy
is but one of the bricks used to build
this structure
uh
procreativity is another
which also has been largely abandoned by
our culture
but these building blocks are the only
things that make a marital union
distinct from any other kind of union
they're the whole point of marriage
to decide on open marriages to tear down
the walls of your house and take shelter
in the rubble and the fact that the
adultery is mutually agreed upon and
consensual doesn't make it any less
adulterous or any better at all really
our culture has developed this idea that
it's okay to commit an evil action if
we're open and honest about it
but that so-called honesty is born from
your pride and your lack of concern for
how your wickedness will hurt those
closest to you
at least a man who hides his affair has
acknowledged first that is base and
shameful and second that it's harmful to
his family but somebody who advertises
infidelity is a sociopath with no shame
he's much further from redemption i
think in his marriage much further from
healing than the guy who claims that
he's staying late for work so that he
can meet his mistress at a motel 6.
i mean it's all bad in the end
of course
and it's why fidelity is the much better
course
that's where you have a real marriage
a loving marriage a marriage that is
actually a marriage
and that is why will smith today much
like his marriage i must say
is cancelled well i hope you enjoyed
that clip from the matt well show if you
did go ahead and hit that subscribe
button right down there so you can stay
up to date on all of our future content